Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一个现在正在进行的激动人心的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am guiding you through two important steps that can help you think about weathering the storm on your journey
这些原则都同样适用。你还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的一小时辅导。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天这期《有抱负的心理学家》播客中，我将引导你完成两个重要的步骤，帮助你思考如何在通往
to becoming whatever type of aspiring psychologist you fancy being. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Summer Soundbites is all about embracing resilience. Now, before you glaze over, let me tell you what that's not. Embracing resilience is not about condoning bad or substandard treatment from others. And whilst you might well have heard it said that a diamond is a chunk of coal that did
成为你心目中任何类型心理学家的旅程中度过难关。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这就是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。夏季短评系列的主题是拥抱韧性。现在，在你感到厌烦之前，让我告诉你它不是什么。拥抱韧性并不是要纵容他人糟糕或不合格的对待。虽然你可能听说过“钻石是煤炭在压力下表现良好而形成的”，
well under pressure, it's actually not true that diamonds are made from coal. They apparently do share some of the same properties, but they are not the same. There's loads of proverbs, isn't there? What doesn't kill you makes you stronger. But really, you do not need to be condoning or putting up with too much stress, too much pressure, too many tasks on your to-do list. If the temperature of the water feels too hot, it's okay to get out and to let that be known and to think about how you can make that a more pleasant and tolerable experience for you and that's why supervision can be really useful too. Do bear in mind the free supervision shaping tool on my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision
但这其实是不对的，钻石并不是由煤炭制成的。它们似乎确实共享一些相同的属性，但它们并不相同。有很多谚语，不是吗？“杀不死你的会让你更强大”。但实际上，你并不需要纵容或忍受过多的压力、过多的负担和待办事项清单上过多的任务。如果水温感觉太烫，你可以选择离开，让别人知道，并思考如何让自己获得更舒适、更可忍受的体验，这就是督导非常有用的原因。请记住我网站上的免费督导塑造工具：www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision
but I think it can be useful to think about the resilience that comes from some of the natural ebb and flow that will come with our lives and that will come with any of our careers. Those ebbs and those flows, those setbacks and failures are a really normal part of any pursuit. And we can absolutely embrace the resilience that comes from viewing these challenges as opportunities for growth and learning? What does it show up for you that might give you new avenues to explore, to grow and to reduce those Achilles heels that you might have? How can we use what we might learn on our journey to becoming a psychologist? Our stepping stones to actually help us to become a more effective psychologist in future. I would love your thoughts on this. Do come and join the free psychology group on Facebook. It is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne
但我认为，思考生活中和职业生涯中自然起伏所带来的韧性是有益的。那些起伏、挫折和失败是任何追求中非常正常的一部分。我们完全可以拥抱这种韧性，将这些挑战视为成长和学习的机会。它向你展示了什么，可能会给你带来新的探索途径，让你成长并减少你可能存在的“阿喀琉斯之踵”？我们如何利用在成为心理学家的旅程中学到的东西？这些垫脚石实际上可以帮助我们在未来成为更有效的心理学家。我很想听听你们的想法。欢迎加入Facebook上的免费心理学小组，即“有抱负的心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community），由Marianne
Trent. Let me know what you think. I will be back along after this break. Hope you enjoy the jingle. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. Do remember the upcoming dates for the free compassionate Q&A. So as you can see on your screen, we have the first of those coming up on Monday, the 4th of September 2023 and that starts at 6pm. A replay will of course be available too and the best place to find the replay is Dr Marianne Trent on YouTube. The second of the sessions is Tuesday the 3rd of October 2023 also at 6pm. Again, a replay is available. And the third and final session to support application season for the Declined Sci but
Trent领导。让我知道你的想法。休息后我会回来。希望你喜欢这段旋律。有太多的技巧和经验可以学习。有太多的事情你可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家》集体。《有抱负的心理学家》集体。《有抱负的心理学家》集体。欢迎回来。请记住即将到来的免费同情心问答环节的日期。正如你在屏幕上看到的，第一个环节将在2023年9月4日星期一晚上6点开始。当然也会有回放，找到回放的最佳地点是YouTube上的Dr Marianne Trent频道。第二个环节是2023年10月3日星期二，同样在晚上6点。同样会有回放。第三个也是最后一个环节，旨在支持临床心理学博士（DClinPsy）的申请季，但
also EdSci is also a similar time of year is going to be Tuesday the 7th of November 2023 at 6pm. Because of the nature of podcasts and YouTube, you might well be watching this out of sequence in the order I created them but the replays if the dates have happened will be available on my YouTube channel Dr Marianne Trent and the final point for Marianne's summer soundbites for today is all about seeking support and mentorship it's about reaching out for support from your peers your supervisors from maybe even past supervisors, that's something I've always really benefited from, or other professionals
教育心理学（EdSci）也是在每年的这个时候，时间是2023年11月7日星期二晚上6点。由于播客和YouTube的性质，你可能是在我创作顺序之外观看的，但如果日期已经过去，回放将在我的YouTube频道Dr Marianne Trent上提供。今天Marianne夏季短评的最后一点是关于寻求支持和指导。这是关于向你的同行、督导，甚至可能是过去的督导寻求支持，这是我一直受益匪浅的事情，或者是其他领域的专业人士。
in the field. It might be that they're not psychologists, that they're people that you respect and you can grow by watching and engaging with. I've always really enjoyed working closely with my CPN colleagues and with my speech and language therapy colleagues and even in the past physiotherapy colleagues too. I believe that connecting with really like-minded people and even sometimes people that might not be like-minded can be transformational to us and our growth and the way that we're able to impact and affect change for the people we work with and the clients we serve and it's all part of the journey you know some of the people i've met along the way i still think so very fondly of and i'm still in contact with too so it's not just about the tangible benefits you know the medals that you've you've acquired during your your rise to being a qualified psychologist sometimes it's about the small things that stack up and give us day-to-day enjoyment and for me a lot of that has been with
他们可能不是心理学家，但他们是你尊重的人，你可以通过观察和互动来成长。我一直很喜欢与我的社区精神科护士（CPN）同事、言语和语言治疗同事，甚至过去与物理治疗同事密切合作。我相信与志同道合的人，甚至有时与志不同道合的人建立联系，对我们和我们的成长，以及我们影响和改变我们所服务客户的方式，都具有变革意义。这都是旅程的一部分，你知道，我一路上遇到的一些人，我至今仍非常怀念，也仍与他们保持联系。所以这不仅仅是关于有形的利益，比如你在成为合格心理学家的过程中获得的奖牌，有时是关于那些积累起来并给我们带来日常快乐的小事，对我来说，很多快乐都来自于
my peers and my colleagues if you're struggling to find your tribe at the moment or if you want to supercharge your tribe do consider coming along and joining inspiring psychologist membership which is led by me you can find information about that either in the show notes by clicking on the link in any of my bios in or on my social channels or if you're watching on youtube it will be in the description with this video it's 30 pounds a month with no minimum term and people do say wonderful things about the membership and how helpful it has been to helping them get their foot in the door and their bums on the seats to become trainee clinical psychologists. I hope you found this episode of Marianne's Summer Soundbites really useful. Well done for making the time to commit to your own learning
我的同行和同事。如果你现在正在努力寻找你的圈子，或者如果你想加强你的圈子，请考虑加入由我领导的“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”。你可以在节目说明中点击我任何个人简介中的链接，或者在我的社交频道上找到相关信息，如果你是在YouTube上观看，它会在视频描述中。每月30英镑，没有最低期限。人们对这个会员计划评价很高，认为它在帮助他们迈出第一步、获得临床心理学实习生职位方面非常有帮助。希望你觉得这期Marianne夏季短评非常有用。为你抽出时间致力于自己的学习
and growth. I'll be back along with the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast from 6 a.m. on Monday. Take care. Be kind to yourself. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
和成长而点赞。我将在周一早上6点带着下一期《有抱负的心理学家》播客回来。保重。善待自己。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这就是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。